when somebody called and said do you
want to go to libya with the gaddafi
foundation
the answer is clearly yes
hi i'm nick gillespie with reason tv and
today we're talking with michael
moynihan who's worked for reason
magazine reason tv and reason.com but is
now
going on to work at vice magazine
and uh work on a book project michael
welcome yes
thanks for having me and goodbye thanks
well thank you uh when did you start
with
reason uh 2007. and uh what was uh what
would you say are your highlights of
your run here
highlights of the run here let me see i
mean i think of it in
in sort of two sections like video
pieces that i
i really enjoyed um you know the pieces
that we did from
with you from um the jon stewart rally
from cpac
of interacting with uh with people who
know nothing about politics but
are holding signs you know i couldn't
hear you
i am specifically talking about you uh
and then uh you know on the magazine and
i did a lot of stuff
you know a lot of book reviews and
things and and um that
i have like a four or five that i'm very
happy about
travel pieces a piece about libya yeah
uh talk a little bit about that uh
because i got a huge response you went
to libya
and what i mean this was pre-revolution
or whatever is going on there now but
what did you find
i went to libya with the gaddafi
foundation actually it was a weird sort
of thing when somebody called and said
do you want to go to libya with the
gaddafi foundation
the answer is clearly yes and it's it's
kind of like when john mccain called
uh sarah palin you don't say no you just
don't you don't say no to a sort of
opportunity like that
and uh what i found there was it was
interesting because before we went we we
talked to a bunch of people that were
affiliated with
the regime that were you know pimping
for the regime
and they told us how much money they
were spending on various things
from um gambling this is all true you
know
parties with beyonce and the rest and
then the kind of uh
that right before you get on a plane and
go to one of the most
um sort of pathetic cities in the world
it's not just
poor it's there's something sort of
pathetic about it when there's pictures
of gaddafi everywhere
you know it's just one big junkyard from
end to end it's a filthy
filthy city tripoli is and you can see
this sort of imperial grandeur of when
italy ran the place um but yeah and what
i what i found there is we met with a
lot of old um
uh or what they claimed were ex-al-qaeda
people that had been reformed
by the libyan government and there was
just you know a hulking man behind them
scribbling down notes at all time
and it was clear that there was a bit of
um coercion going on so yeah so there's
a classic sort of john reed
uh you know i mean i mean what they were
trying to do is
i mean it's a junket to try and get
positive views of
the qaddafi regime in libya which worked
on some people i want to yeah i actually
want to point out nobody
naming anybody in particular and i
didn't actually name anybody in the
piece
is that of the people that i went with
there was only one person there
that didn't buy it besides i'd say
besides myself and i'm talking to very
very smart people
who were incredibly dumb when faced with
this stuff oh really yeah they were
impressed oh they were impressed by it
yeah no
it was very much um you know imagining
yourself like being
malcolm muggerage or something in
stalin's i mean these people really
bought
it and you know we talked to um
ex-al-qaeda libyan islamic fighting
group guys
who um said you know we've been we've
been cured by this program
and but now they are homosexuals
gonna have to be cured of something else
yeah it's just very complicated but you
know these people that we went into this
um
to these interviews with actually did
buy they were drinking the kool-aid and
our on our kind of exit
um session we were all sitting talking
and um
everyone said you know they've this is a
really interesting model they've
produced and uh
and there were almost no skeptics do you
think if gaddafi
had used a different color he would have
been more successful
orange like the orange revolution was so
successful in the ukraine yeah maybe
yeah but he's
he wears those green sashes he's a very
handsome man
yeah uh now you're uh moving on to vice
magazine what are you gonna be doing
there and uh tell us a little bit about
what vice is up to
uh what vice is up to is you know i read
vice magazine when i lived in
new york previously uh back in the 90s
and early 2000s
and uh you know basically a culture
magazine that does
um it's not expressly political it's not
i would say it's not political at all
and um but they're doing i mean a lot of
guys there that seem to have
you know gotten older and have more
interest in and
you know rather than just you know kids
riding fixed gear bikes and getting
tattoos it's
you know what's going on in the world
and doing a lot of stuff in
sort of you know they did a piece on
libya um around the same time we talked
to
talked about that um which was one of
the points of contact with us they went
on the very same two of the guys went on
the very same trip
um you know they did a very did they buy
the uh
the cadavers yeah i don't even really
think that they were even thinking about
it to be honest
uh judging from the piece um but no they
and you know a piece on north korea that
got a lot of got a lot of attention
so i mean there's kind of a focus more
on you know being a little newsier
right um and so i'll be uh hopefully
bringing
you know that kind of you know a little
more attention less
less about um just straight up pop
culture straight pop culture to
something
that's sort of more of a nexus of pop
culture and news so
and then uh you've also got a book idea
in the works can you talk to
that yeah the book idea which um you
know is now in the very tedious process
of putting together a long and
detailed um book proposal is something
that is tentatively titled junk history
and it's something actually that you
know you asked before of what i was
happy with
happiness with a reason um i did a lot
of work on on
just kind of by default it just kind of
kept on coming up was
um the uses and abuses of history for
political
political purposes you know the
politician or the political actor
will take you know the the appropriate
sort of bits of history to try to make a
historical
or to make a political argument by using
history rather than letting the facts
take them where it may
and so you know whether it's uh glenn
beck on the right or howard zinn on the
left
uh people that have really distorted
kind of history for
political ends and uh just the people
that uh
um um doing this i mean it's a very hard
kind of thing so
so you're going to be looking at the
ways in which the howard zins of the
world or the glenn beck's
the ken burns's yeah i know even that i
mean there is polite company
right sort of bourgeois um appropriate
uh chin stroking canvas bag toting junk
history too
you're interested in history obviously
but is there uh what
what are the guidelines for a non-junk
history because i mean
you can always create a usable passage
sure i mean it's it's a
infinite kind of rummage sale where you
can piece together any narrative you
want and have evidence for any thesis so
what
what should guide the proper use of
history yeah no it is the sort of
pomo question isn't it of like you know
what what is history and can we say
in history what is true right and we can
to a certain extent we can say that you
know the japanese bombed pearl harbor on
december 7th 1941.
that we can say um everything else and
that franklin roosevelt ordered the
attack
yes yeah look you know and there are
a lot of it kind of trespasses on
conspiracy too
and there are people that i think are
laboring
um you know from a political standpoint
that are coming that are writing really
really smart histories
um the ones that become like the glenn
beck stuff is a good example of this i
think
which is learning history as you're
teaching it
right and for purposes
that have nothing to do with the study
of history it is
you know uh barack obama is in a sort of
maoist tradition
that is just simply untrue i mean there
is i mean look no matter how much i
object to the economic policies of our
current president you cannot
in sort of good conscience or in good
faith compare it to somebody who's
killed
you know 65 million people or something
so you're
saying that uh obama is much worse he is
far worse
he's sort of the uh pol pot from 1600
pennsylvania
yeah yeah so uh so then what what guides
uh the proper use of history
well look i mean i think that in in i
mean this is all the stuff that i'm
gonna be focusing on individual examples
and then kind of a broader thing of
of what is and is not junk history it's
much in the way that
junks when we come across junk science
like you see something that reason has
done a lot of good work on drunk science
and you know ron
bailey is a great example of this and i
think is one of the most
honest writers out there and when you
know
when his you know who was the famous
person who said uh i can't remember you
know
um you know what happens uh when the
evidence changed i changed my mind and
ron this has
happened to ron um obviously and you
know i think that like ron is somebody
who's investigating something from a
standpoint
of a critical standpoint rather than
somebody
who is looking at it to say well how
much legislation can we get out of this
right you see that with three mile
island you see this with you know the
nuke disaster in japan
it's looking at a situation looking at
the science
in a sort of secondary way and seeing
how much kind of control we can bring
out right
there is a there is kind of a historical
analog with that too
is to use um history as saying well you
know
x is just like y in history and those
comparisons never match up
right and they're not you know so the
historiography of it is more about
politics
than it is about sort of you know and as
as you know
historians fight about these things they
fight about them all the time of what
events mean what i'm talking about more
is more
sort of excising events just you know
kind of exact doing out things
for the purpose of you know getting a
political result
and it's you know it's always going to
be there it's always been with us
why does it happen how does it happen
how do we sort of prevent it
is now and this is i think the more most
important point or
interesting point is is now a special
time right
it's always argued we've done things
that reason about this is the debate
especially hot right now and that isn't
the case
and what i would the argument i would
make right now before actually getting
too
deep into the the sort of process of
writing this is that
um junk history is probably um we're in
a better place now than we ever have
been
and it's been it's been much much worse
than that and that's because more people
participate in the conversation yes
absolutely i mean look there is
you know this birther stuff where right
filming this right after
the long-form birth certificates
released so obviously a lot of people
are going to
um you know we know that from polls a
lot of people believe this sort of stuff
but for those you can't avoid that these
are people that are not politically
engaged they're not interested in being
politically engaged
they get snatches of information here
and there for those that are engaged i
mean even sort of
you know moderately engaged um junk
history is much much better than it's
ever been and where it's in a position
where it's being debunked
more openly with more sources and in
sort of a wiki way
is that you know you can't get away with
putting inserting something into a
wikipedia entry
without having a mass of other people
saying well you know there are questions
about
you know whether the atomic bomb was
right or wrong yeah and those are open
historical debates i mean
so i think that it's a it's a really
really perfect time right now
because technology is allowing people to
have more people to have this debate
right so
well thank you uh thank you for your
contributions to reason and good luck
uh we'll look for you in the uh funny
pages from here on out
for reason tv i'm nick gillespie
you